let's jump into this first story we got
this from timcast.com we got a couple
things actually quote unelected World
Government musk further comments on
world economic forum meaning in Davos
would be great if someone could compile
a game contest of who said the craziest
stuff between 4chan and the world
economic Forum I love it he recently put
up this uh this Twitter poll so if you
guys are on Twitter you can go uh click
that no button the world economic Forum
should control the world yes no
1.6 million people said I voted and 13
so we're looking at like 200 000 people
said yes
I'm thinking a lot about world economic
Forum lately and Klaus Schwab obsessed
with like stakeholder capitalism
shareholder capitalism evolving the
system the the economic and I'm like you
know what he's missing out on his
statehood like statehood is comes before
economic your economic system statehood
is a concept that exists without
economics you don't need and Klaus has
Obsessed all he focuses on its economics
and the economic structure of things
he's missing out on the political
structure of things which is I think
Paramount is that we have statehood we
have local Central local government
where like you have decentralized
structures of authority that's key
you're missing the pointer that's not
what they want they want centralization
they want all the power in their hands
they don't want statehood they don't
want sovereignty they don't want
independence they don't want you being
proud of where you're from they want to
break you apart they want to play a
larger divide and conquer agenda as they
take everything else for themselves
because how else would they be able to
get as rich as they are without them
running larger Ponzi schemes on everyone
else in inside of the not only the
United States but the entire world and
the kind conversations happening at
Davos I've been paying attention to them
they're creepy they're they're out of
the 1984 orwellian hellscape you can't
even imagine the horrors that these
people are describing and they're
cheering it on talking about like it's
going to be incredible when you guys
don't have any red meat when you have
mandatory requirement of of making sure
that that you are reporting your carbon
emissions making sure that there's going
to be regulations on speech regulations
on Bitcoins uh there's going to be
Global cyber attacks there's going to be
you know major attacks against free
speech and they're like yeah this is
great this is awesome we need Central
Bank digital currencies we need uh
places where you can't leave where
you're going to be stuck in with
15-minute sustainable communities this
is absolutely crazy what they're doing
and they deserve to be countered because
their policies are becoming law who are
these laws serving what they're serving
what's a 15-minute community so they're
testing this actually in the United
Kingdom right now it's where you're
going to need permission to cross over
from one one neighborhood to another
where everything is 15 minutes uh inside
of your community so you don't need a
car so you get to walk or you get to
ride around in your bike to have a car
and go from one Community to another
you're only allowed a certain amount of
times to do that then you need
government permission in order to just
travel in your car and the main idea is
to keep you in a prison to keep you in a
grid where you are stuck and this is a
pilot program that's going to be
happening in a major UK town in just a
few years from now that they're going to
be instituting with surveillance cameras
artificial intelligence facial
recognition plate reading cameras making
sure that you are essentially living in
a prison yeah yeah but but This only
affects poor people right so you know
the rich people don't got to worry about
it is that is that is that well depends
how rich are you in the club are you
sacrificing you know yeah Trump's not
rich enough you know what I mean exactly
how they like borders yes a lot of
borders and they want more borders uh in
order to control people better there's a
reason Klaus Schwab says China is the
model for the world that's because
they've been testing a lot of their
latest technocratic technology and
enslavement of humanity in that country
now they're going to be rolling it out
everywhere else what's what's this cyber
911 stuff they've been talking about
they've been talking about that for a
long time they had a war game a couple
months ago where they actually worked
with the Russian government simulating
larger cyber attacks that were supposed
to be happening on the world and how
they would deal with that this is very
similar to event 201 where a lot of the
fairies a very same kind of central
players in uh covid were talking about a
pandemic situation that they were
training for and drilling for right
before covid happened so a couple months
ago their training uh specifically a
drill called cyber polygon where they
specifically were doing these larger
tests of what's going to happen when
everything in our online infrastructure
gets shut down and is weaponized against
the people how are they going to be
responding to it this as they're saying
and kind of foretelling that their next
kind of bigger psyops the next kind of
bigger terrorist attack is going to be
on line is going to be digital and is
going to be affecting everyone and
potentially could have already started a
couple days ago especially what would
happen with the FAA with them
essentially shutting down and not
allowing airplane traffic for two hours
in the United States first time ever
since 9 11. as a Cyber attack that did
that right potentially we don't know yet
we don't know exact details here but I
get I get riled up against this this so
much because the writing's on the wall
they talk about this they brag about
this they literally have all these
articles and documents uh where they're
like yes this is how we're going to
implement this vision of you being a
slave and us having all the power over
you sorry you want to say something on a
tangent here no it's an extremely
important information they do like to
tout it it sounds less like uh hey you
guys should all watch out for this in
more of a hey this is what we're
planning to do next so we're just kind
of troubleshooting the social effects
and so it almost seems like oh Bank of
America shut down oh FAA and they just
okay when Airlines go down this is what
they do when they electricity goes out
this one there's no money this so
they're catering to our responses I
believe and I actually tweeted about
this I said hey WF is talking about a
Cyber attack and uh the governments are
talking about it but when we bring it up
they call us conspiracy theorists and uh
Elon actually responded to the tweet and
he just wrote under it starlink
yeah man that's what you ultimately I
don't know if it's unhackable but you
need systems outside the system like
Klaus this top-down Authority thing
doesn't work with statehood you can't
make it happen when local authorities
have control and communication and
delivery of goods like if you have drone
delivery services like we can get Jeff
Bezos Amazon to create like a orbital
drone delivery system along with Elon
starlink I think we're really talking
about some sort of Freedom like well
their enemy is statehood their their
enemy is nationalism their enemy is
pride in in one's country because once
you get rid of that you could allow
people to be internationalists because
when you destroy a nation for the
personal benefit of the few these people
don't care about the United States they
don't care about the Constitution
contrary to a lot of people's beliefs
they hate the Constitution they hate
that people have the First Amendment and
the Second Amendment and they're doing
everything in their power they're and
manipulating people as much as they can
they're doing so many underhanded things
in order to make sure that the rule of
law the Constitution the most important
rights that are extremely rare in human
history are obliterated and destroyed
that's exactly what they did in China
and what they did in China is what
they're going to be doing to the rest of
the world very soon because a lot of
their policies that they called for are
literally being implemented slowly and
surely look what happened to Sri Lanka
they complied that was another major
test of the compliance system Sri Lanka
had a 98 ESG social credit score World
economic Forum saying Sri Lanka is going
to be the best country out there what's
happening to Sri Lanka right now energy
shortages the schools are shut down
businesses are shut down energy
rationing government taxing every little
aspect of your life but they have
diversity are you talking about they
have California or yes this is this is
this is their planned destruction of our
life and this is why California this is
why New Zealand this is why Australia
this is why the United Kingdom the
Netherlands and Sri Lanka are all
adopting the same policies at the same
time top down centralized control of the
control the demolition of the entire
Western world that's what we're seeing
right now it's serious and the
implications here are going to be very
severe been I think we were talking a
little about before the show about the
king of England and that his ties to the
world economic Forum I'm not a not too
super he's one of the early kind of
co-founders of the world economic forum
and you'll you'll see him uh it's
actually kind of interesting when they
bring him on stage I don't know if you
guys can find the video but they put
like the fleur-de-lis behind him and
it's like a crown over his head right
when he's speaking he is I think that
the wef I am very confident is his way
of expanding England's imperialist uh
intentions through the back door they're
like oh we don't need to put red coats
in every country we just need to control
the top players in government media uh
and business and then we can have a lot
of control you know King Charles uh or
Klaus Schwab he talks about how we have
people in the Canadian Parliament and in
the Canadian cabinets in New Zealand and
Canada New Zealand and Australia are all
constitutional monarchies ultimately
subject to the authority of King Charles
and which three countries were the most
oppressive during the cover lockdowns
with the mandatory vaccines with you
know vaccine passports it was those
three countries and Israel concentration
camps China really I think but the thing
about China is they're so loud in
Western countries remember when those
three kids escaped from that uh was it
Howard Springs facility and then all
these like woke people were like no no
no it's not a concentration camp it's
just for people who are sick and they're
posting like bikini-clad women like like
you know looking all happy meanwhile
three native like uh indigenous
Australian kids like through burlap
sacks over the barbed wire and tried to
climb out and Escape because they were
forcefully relocated and they had
checkpoints because of that they they
literally locked down entire cities
looking for these three kids which were
a danger to society they were
imprisoning people and putting them in
quarantine camps because they had
disagreements and arguments with police
officers who are just sick of someone
and said you know what you tested
positive even though they did not and
those photos are actually from the
Olympics and a lot of the Australian
Olympic team were using that facility
previously before and that's where they
got all the pictures of all the hot
babes but essentially it was just uh you
know a camp that the government it
detained you for as long as they wanted
to without you having any kind of
recourse is an important point to be
made though
look at what happened with Claire Lehman
from Colette she was this free speech
advocate
living in Australia then Australia goes
full death star and she immediately
Falls in line and says never it's all
okay everything they're doing is
completely fine you're all wrong that's
how quickly you know some of these
people's uh Integrity holds up if you
ever wanted to know what it like what
it's like what you're gonna do when
tyranny takes over you just found out
the last three years how you responded
that was the greatest psychological
operation ever conducted on Humanity in
the history of the world and if you went
through that and obviously you know if
you didn't get the jab or if you
resisted the mass or whatever you know
pat yourself on the back because that's
quite impressive I think America I think
they're actually I think we actually
achieved a huge Victory and I do want to
give a lot of credit to the Canadian
truckers they set the wheels in motion
but I think they're like crap we still
had despite all that despite trillions
of of propaganda
thirty percent forty percent of
Americans did not fully comply and it's
probably going to be worse the second
time around yeah yeah it was like
inoculation for me it was the rat hope
experiment we've talked about it you
familiar with it
no dude takes three cylinders full of
water and some rats puts the rats in the
cylinders they swim for 15 minutes and
then give up and die he then takes
another group of rats puts them in the
cylinders they swim for 15 minutes give
up but then he grabs them and pulls them
out dries him off lets them rest puts
them back in the second time they swam
for 60 hours oh because when they had
hope they were they they they said I'm
not going to give up
the first group of rats were just like I
have no idea what's happening I'm tired
this is it I'm done
second group of rats were like I will be
saved the hand will come back and they
kept swimming it's the first time I've
been appreciating being called a rat
that's crazy now imagine the experiments
that the CIA are working on right now
that we don't even know about probably
with very similar situations very
similar circumstances but instead of
rats they're probably doing it well
they're human beings that's what people
think about the lockdowns the lockdowns
were the first 15 minutes and then
everybody started to lose their minds
then they okay everybody we're going
back to normal everybody come back out
come back out they're gonna re-lock down
so the hypothesis goes and this time
they're going to be like don't don't
worry just like last time we'll we'll
lift the lockdown soon it's coming it's
coming but people will go 300 times
longer in lockdown I got a little bit of
a different take from that is that the
the willingness to resist and then their
in inability to enforce it is the Hope
like that's us getting pulling ourselves
out of the tank realizing like oh you
don't have to submit to this yeah
personally I just see things a little
bit differently I don't think they're
going to try to launch another kind of
pandemic from here I think it's going to
be digital I think there's going to be
an attack on our infrastructure it's
going to lead to a lot of chaos and then
they're going to come in and saying hey
it's dangerous to have an open and free
internet we need to take control of it
and that's the last thing that's the
last step that they need fully
controlling the internet fully taking it
over from people like Elon Musk and
other individuals that are still
allowing Free Speech everything and
saying this is now in our control for
your safety and your health and
well-being just one more point before we
move on to this particular story uh
Robert Kennedy Jr actually just did a
very fascinating interview that I just
uh retweeted talking about how the
central controllers people at the CIA
during covid weren't looking up for your
best interest weren't talking about and
and making studies and looking into how
to help people how to give them early
treatments he goes on and talks about
how the CIA used the covid-19 response
to increase their top-down government
authoritarianism and totalitarianism and
had this as an opportunity to run many
psychological operations to see what
they could get away with this is Robert
Kennedy Jr fascinating video just
tweeted about it um thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time